>>Student: Well, that juice is--
>>Jeff: Slide that level down here.
Let's just double-check what we did,
We're looking to see if the
bubble is between the lines.
>>Students: It is!
>>Jeff: Nice work, people.
>>Barbara: They are asking
the questions.
They are doing the research.
It is about that hands-on
learning, and it allows teachers
to be able to make it all real.
>>Courtney: I don't like
that word, "Can't."
>>Courtney: We are starting a process
of really going down the STEAM road
of understanding how arts can
be integrated with science,
technology, engineering and math.
We push the students
to see the connections.
We inspire them with real-world
opportunities to make those connections.
>>Teacher: What angle
do we need to put it?
>>Barbara: Engineering helps them to
critically think and problem solve.
Ms. Bryant teaches those
concepts through art design.
Which is perfect for young children.
>>Courtney: There isn't
really a state-wide curriculum
for elementary school,
engineering design.
But looking at where they need to be
in middle school and then high school,
I'm able to backwards design
for the elementary level.
>>Courtney: Then once this dries,
we'll flip it and get the sides.
>>Jeff: Here in the engineering
lab, we do design-and-build projects
that involve students,
surprisingly young.
You wouldn't think that first and second
graders could do perspective rendering
and design concepts,
but they're doing it!
>>Jaron: Well, we're making
things for the Tinker Yard.
And we're kind of making
a house like right here.
>>Louis: We're building it so people
can think of energy when they see it,
and then people want to go in here.
>>Girl: To play.
>>Louis: It's like another playground.
>>Courtney: The Tinker Yard happens
to be four stations that
they've come up with.
The first station is a Building Station.
>>Jeff: Kids love to build forts, so
we just give them an eclectic amount
of materials that they can fasten
together and make structures.
And those structures constantly change
and shift as they take them apart,
put them back together
in different ways.
>>Courtney: The last station
is the Energy Station.
That's the piece that
we're working on now.
>>Jeff: And it's a raised platform that
will allow us to mount different kinds
of simple machines that
the kids can operate.
>>Courtney: I'm going to
start adding to our drawing.
We can add parts from the bicycle,
we can also add parts from our wagon.
So Terrance, what should I add?
>>Terrance: Get a chain and attach it
to the little gear he
made and make it roll.
>>Jeff: It's starting to happen.
>>Courtney: One of the things
that's neat about doing a project
like this is it provides an entry point,
and then a real world application.
So we're doing research about what
possible simple machines they could use.
>>Courtney: This is a
simple machine called--
>>Student: Plane, incline plane.
>>Courtney: Incline plane, very good!
>>Courtney: The next thing we're
talking about is idea development,
where they're generating
sketches to show off their idea.
It's one thing for someone to
be able to talk about an idea,
but to actually put it on paper makes
it a lot more concrete for a student.
>>Aeris: When you pull
the gear, the wheel spins.
>>Courtney: So the next step
is to synthesize designs.
Students sharing and
drawing on each other's work.
>>Courtney: She added a wheel, and she
added some shapes with a spring here.
>>Aeris: Brian, do you
want to work on mine?
>>Courtney: And then we'll
start to piece it together.
It is design-by-committee, but the
committees are second-grade students.
The fourth graders are working on a
Dream Cars Project-Based Learning Unit.
They're learning about
composition and materials and use.
Their project is going to
be to create a dream car
and design it for a particular customer.
>>Courtney: Before we draw our vanishing
points, you're right, what do we need?
Horizon line!
>>Students: Ooooh!
>>Courtney: They're at the phase now
of starting the sketching process.
>>Courtney: One of the ways you
communicate is through your drawing.
This is not a drawing class, but I
want you to see that it is important
to learn how to do it, and do it well,
so that you can show off your idea.
A monster truck, you decide--
>>Courtney: The next step after that
would be actually modeling it in 3D.
And they're gonna see how it's a
lot easier to model it out of clay,
if you have the sketch onboard.
>>Courtney: Most people don't
learn two-point perspective
until they're much older.
I didn't learn it until high school.
But I must have a lot
of confidence in you.
I know that you guys have got this.
>>Courtney: Rubrics are a big part
of the assessment strategy
for engineering design.
When you're talking about a
design process, the first thing
that you're given is a brief.
This is what your boss--
that would be me--
is looking for at the
end of the project.
>>Courtney: Look on your rubric now,
and tell me what does
Kaleigh earn based on that.
A 100, which is the equivalent
to a check-plus.
>>Courtney: The students will
evaluate themselves at the end
to see whether they met the goals.
>>Jeff: Problem solving through design.
A lot of students, that's
how they learn.
That kinesthetic-spatial-tactile
kind of knowing.
They get to come in here and that's part
of how they understand what's
going on in engineering.
>>Courtney: The value of
brainstorming, and not just rushing
without thinking all
the aspects through,
having success after many
failures, so persistence.
>>Jeff: Get it in there, and
then pull the trigger again.
There we go!
>>Courtney: That type of real world
experience they're going to carry
that with them for the
rest of their life.